the fate of a Missouri prisoner on death
row is in doubt after the state's
governor resigned last month he had
delayed the execution of Marcellus
Williams scheduled for last summer
Williams was convicted of murder for the
1998 killing of Felicia Gale Jim Axelrod
talked with family members and activists
who believe Williams is innocent
he's in st. Louis Jim good morning well
good morning when former Missouri
governor Eric Greitens issued that today
he impaneled the special board to
examine the facts of the case and make a
recommendation but then a personal
scandal forced Greitens out leaving the
board in jeopardy and the future of
Marcellus Williams entirely unclear just
thinking about that day it was crazy
Marcellus Williams jr. prepared for his
father's execution last August I mean my
father we said our goodbyes you actually
said goodbye to your dad mm-hmm you said
he loved each other you know I loved him
he loved me but just hours before the
execution former Missouri governor Eric
Greitens granted Marcellus Williams
senior a temporary stay Williams is on
death row for the 1998 murder of Felicia
Gale he's convicted of stabbing the
former st. Louis post-dispatch newspaper
reporter 43 times with a butcher knife
there's enough doubt in this case that
he his sentence should at least be
commuted Innocence Project co-founder
Barry Scheck the skin cells on the
handle of the knife that was used in
this murder hmm are not from him when
Greitens issued pardons before leaving
office in June Williams was not one of
them why do you think he chose not to
you know I'm really not sure you know
it's like maybe he also never cared you
know so he's like oh I'm leaving I don't
care you know I do these five poisons
and my cell is he can he can rot while
in office
Greitens asked a special five-person
board to review the case now that he's
gone that board has been cancelled new
Missouri governor Michael Parsons I know
the board was cancelled will they meet
will they make a recommendation to you
and what will you do that I would assume
they would I've heard they're not going
to so I think once they make that wreck
if they do meet then we'll discuss at
the time we've been following the case
for a year activists and social media
influencer Alison Brettschneider learned
of the case days before Williams
scheduled execution and has since become
an advocate for his exoneration you're
not a lawyer you're not a politician
what are you bringing to this I'm a
person that cares and that's what the
world needs more of the Missouri
Attorney General's Office maintains
Williams is guilty though Williams was
not linked to the murder weapon police
found Gail's clothing and her husband's
computer in Williams car in a statement
the Attorney General's Office told CBS
News we will continue to defend the
judgment of the jury and the many courts
that have carefully reviewed mr.
Williams case over 16 years in addition
of first degree murder Williams has been
convicted of burglary assault and
attempted armed robbery when people say
to you hey your dad was no Eagle Scout
right what's the answer to that but he
didn't harm so slap punch and it killed
anyone
someone did murder Lisa Gill but it
wasn't my father
in a statement to CBS News Felicia gales
family said while we understand that
Williams sentencing fits a troubling
pattern of racial disparity in the death
penalty and that a case serious enough
to warrant death is serious enough to
warrant careful scrutiny we would ask
those on all sides to recognize for the
family this is not policy it is pain
Gale a lot of questions there thank you
very much Jim